à présent du front diplomatique et prêts
notamment cette adresse de nouveau aux
europe et on va en parler avec vous
armer le charrier bonjour armelle elle a
vu ces derniers jours les canaux de
communication avec vladimir poutine
n'ont pas été rompus c'est une bonne
chose nous assure à tous les experts de
cette crise échanges téléphoniques qui
hier encore avec josep borrell nombreux
échanges avec emmanuel macron froid le
chef de l'état français qui fait partie
du fait forcément de son poste à la tête
de la présidence de l'union européenne
des partenaires avec qui il communique
le plus sain le chef du kremlin
aujourd'hui oui vladimir poutine
effectivement toujours dit qu'il était
quand même réceptif au dialogue
pourquoi parce que d'abord il a intérêt
lui a montré qu'il est capable de
pouvoir encore discuter avec les uns et
les autres il ya un fait notable à ce
jour malgré tout les sanctions malgré
tout ce qui se passe sur le terrain
vladimir poutine n'a pas coupé le gaz à
l'europe on a encore du gaz qui arrive
en allemagne en france au demeurant
d'ailleurs on en a plus que jamais parce
que il ya les échanges n'ont jamais été
aussi importants peut-être parce que ça
rapporte aussi de l'argent à vladimir
poutine mais aussi parce que tout le
monde a eu peur et donc essaie au
maximum d'en avoir et que le gaz c'est
beaucoup plus discret puisque ça passe
par des oléoducs que le pétrole le
pétrole par contre si vous voulez à dire
que vous achetez du pétrole russe
forcément vous avez des bateaux qui
arrivent qui vont livrer donc visible ça
veux vous dire que la diplomatie il ya
ce qu'ils s'affichent et ce qui se fait
en réalité
vraisemblablement vladimir poutine a
intérêt à garder un canal de discussion
jusqu'au moment où il sera dans le
rapport de forces qu'il jugera lui être
favorable à les discuter réellement avec
les ukrainiens en attendant cela lui
permet aussi de prendre le pouls des uns
et des autres et puis de parler de la
question des civils de parler la
question des réfugiés de parler de la
question aussi des corridors
humanitaires lors on voit que pour
l'instant ce n'est pas encore mise en
place cela dit les russes avancent
j'allais dire de façon très classique
finalement dans leur conquête militaire
de l'ukraine ils font des villes à 6 g
on c'est le cas de marioupol ils ont
plutôt intérêt à ce que les personnes
âgées sorte de mario paul sorte de
kharkiv sorte de kiev alors pour
l'instant ce n'est pas encore tout à
fait faisable mais un jour ou l'autre
ils le feront et ça fait partie
justement des marges de négociation
qu'ils ont dans ce genre de situation
dans ce contexte évidemment il ne faut
négliger aucune initiative pour
enclencher une désescalade la chine se
propose un rôle de médiateur emmanuel
macron va s'entretenir d'ailleurs avec
avec son homologue et quel genre le
médiateur fait qu'un petit l'être
aujourd'hui ça peut être un vrai
médiateur la chine un vrai médiateur
parce que jusqu'à présent on discutait
toujours de ce pays comme à voix comme
et ayant une place économique or les
chinois ont envie je vous rappelle
d'avoir une hégémonie grand mondial de
remplacer les américains à long terme
donc à partir du moment donné où ils
gravissent la marche de pouvoir se
positionner comme quelqu'un avec lequel
on va discuter politiquement il pousse
un peu de côté les états unis où même
les européens qui le font régulièrement
vous rappeler que emmanuel macron et
beaucoup pas là la barre sur ces
questions là parce que c'est président
de la france parce que c'est le
président de l'europe parce que c'est
aussi un président en campagne
électorale en france mais les chiens ont
intérêt du coup à jouer de toutes ses
cartes là c'est aujourd'hui le
partenaire économique de la russie quand
il ya eu effectivement des arrêts sur le
fait qu'on pouvait envoyer aux uns ou
aux autres la chine donné 12%
aujourd'hui aux russes maintenant il en
soit 42% donc on voit qu'il augmente et
il joue effectivement cette carte à la
fois économiques et politiques merci
beaucoup à melle charest alors que
d'autres pays comme la turquie